thank you for joining our webinar
aggregating and sharing clinical
evidence to improve the diagnosis of
rare diseases
my name is ben liesfeld from limbus
medical technologies
i'm going to talk today about how to
apply
whole exome sequencing in routine
diagnostics
by the way if you have any questions
during the talk
feel free to ask the questions in the
chat
i will be happy to follow up with them
by email after the webinar
i will touch four topics
during my talk first i'm going to
explain a little what is holding us back
actually
whole exome sequencing has been around
for a few years now
but it's still not widely used and it's
certainly not used
as a first-line diagnostic why is that
we'll look at this in more detail
and we will highlight the critical steps
and the whole exome sequencing process
and i will explain what the potential
pitfalls are
and then i will show you a validated
solution
that enables you to actually achieve an
optimum process
in diagnostics and i will explain
with a few clinical examples what the
specific benefits of a validated
solution
for this process are so first of all
why is whole exon sequencing not
performed as first line diagnostic
everywhere
there are a few issues that are most
frequently
raised so the first one is typically
whole exome sequencing is too expensive
it's not worth the money compared to
target sequencing
the second issue is that review is
too difficult people don't feel prepared
to do the job
it's very time consuming and there are
typically too many variants to review
and third this all causes
the turnaround time to be very long it
takes a long time
to return results to the patient and
many of those results are inconclusive
so you can't cannot even give the
patient an answer
and this is something that not only
small laboratories which are starting
are start struggling with it's also
large and very experienced institutions
who
are struggling to achieve a high
diagnostic yield
from whole exome sequencing let's take a
look at the whole
exome sequencing process in more detail
this is a very crude depiction of the
process
and the steps are somewhat arbitrary but
on the left side of the on the left hand
side you can see
the wet lab process starting from dna
extraction
library preparations actually sequencing
and on the right hand side it's
rather the software processing the data
processing and the interpretation
steps the bioinformatics filtering and
the reporting
and so we have identified in our work
with our customers that well
since you are since the uh sequencing
instruments have matured so far they
have grown to a large capacity and they
are generating data
in large batches and you're then
struggling to
actually process all this data in the
next step
and you're mostly most of the time even
getting slower
when trying to interpret these large
amounts of variance so
what are the critical steps and where
have do you have to pay attention
in order to streamline the process and
to maintain
high throughput through all the steps so
actually one of the wet lab steps
we identified as very critical and whole
exome sequencing that's the library
preparation
and the issues that you may face there
are you may have a gc bias and you may
not even be
aware that there is a gc bias or there
may be
other reasons why the coverage in your
targeted sequencing is non-uniform
or you may have great variability across
samples
or across batches of samples and all
these
issues impact how the downstream
processing
and the interpretation can go on
and see you may have impact on the
diagnostic yield
because you have gaps in coverage and
some of
those issues may impact the sensitivity
in the cnv analysis
and in total um the whole process the
entire essay will not be cost efficient
because you
have to compensate for those issues in
the library preparation
so it really makes sense to address
those to identify those issues in the
first place
and to address this in the very first
step
another critical step in the process is
certainly the bioinformatics
and what we've seen in the field so far
are setups that are incapable of
reliably
calling cnvs in the data
software setups that are not
standardized that are not even validated
that require a number of manual steps
and those setups are certainly not
scalable to a degree that is required in
routine diagnostics
and this impacts of course the
diagnostic yields
if you cannot even see copy number
variations you cannot report on them
and they may make up a significant
fraction of your cases
you will have variability in the quality
and then the
and the results of your diagnosis you
will have prolonged processing time you
will have a bottleneck here
and in general you will push workload
from the bioinformatics
into the interpretation part so
for example the reporting team will
spend a lot of time
figuring out if a variant is actually
there that so they have to do a lot of
quality control
and this is the wrong place to do that
this just creates
workload where it shouldn't be
and the third critical step that we
mostly address is the filtering and the
classification of variants
and the issues that you may be facing
there is that you
have too many variants that you are
supposed to review
that information that you need and that
you're utilizing
is distributed across many tools
and that you have too many inconclusive
results and the reason for that is
probably that you have
not sufficient reference data data to be
able to
compare the variance in your patient to
and this will impact your ability
to correctly interpret the significance
of variance this will impact your
ability to
actually perform diagnosis or in your
patient and
it will impact the turnaround around
time it will extend the turnaround time
to
a long period of time and this means
that costs
are increasing this part actually in the
workflow
involves the most expensive labor there
is in the laboratory
and you want to to structure this as
efficiently as possible
so overall these issues may
impact your ability to apply whole exome
sequencing
in routine diagnostics in general
i stressed the term reference data and
the ability to
use it in the previous slide and so what
is reference data actually and
what can it be used for so the first
thing that comes into mind when talking
about reference data in genomics
is of course databases collections of
known variants variants are that have
been reported before
of course one of those databases would
be clinvar or you could also consult
mastermind which is a very comprehensive
database of
published literature and if you're
looking for copy number variations you
would probably
consult decipher another source of
information
which is reference data is information
about
known phenotype relationships so
relationships
between genes and phenotypes that have
been described before
and you could find those information in
the human phenotype ontology
or in the omim database and the third
kind of reference data is generated from
healthy reference populations one
example is
the gnome database or the ggb
database if you're thinking about copy
number variations
and last but not least there is a source
of information that we call
real world evidence it's called that
because it's not being generated or has
not been generated
during controlled clinical studies but
it's continuously
generated during routine diagnostics
so it's made up of data created from
real patients it could be that this kind
of data is
located in proprietary in-house
databases
so there are some large institutions who
have the manpower
and the funding to maintain and to
create those
proprietary databases but you may also
find real world
evidence and aggregated databases where
several institutions contribute and
share information so how can
this uh how can these kinds these types
of reference data be used
when diagnosing patients when analyzing
whole exomes
so there are different purposes of these
data types so first of all the known
variants you can use
to reduce the number of false negatives
they help you
avoid to miss a variant to miss a
variant that has been previously
reported and
in the same way the phenotype
information works
it helps you to prioritize to rank
the genes and to the degree that they
overlap with the known phenotype of the
patient
so they help you to reduce numbers or
false positive false negatives
and the then on the other hand the
reference data from healthy populations
work
exactly the opposite opposite way they
help you to
filter out all variants that just appear
too frequently
across healthy populations and therefore
the simple argument is
what is occurring to too frequently
cannot be pathogenic this is a thinking
that
is valid in this setting of dealing with
um single gene diseases and
where the explanation is a single
variant
and last but not least the real world
evidence gives you both
it gives you the ability to reduce
reduce false positives
like the healthy reference populations
because every patient that is contained
in this real world evidence database
can serve as a control for the patient
that you currently look at
because pathogenic variants are just so
rare
and the reward evidence can also serve
to reduce the number of false negatives
of course
because you have access to additional
evidence
to be able to classify variance as
pathogenic
i'd like to explain a little bit more
what the quality of the data
is that is contained in real world
evidence databases
if you compare or if you're looking in
more detail at nomad you know
it's gnomid is a database it has been
built
from data obtained from healthy
adults it has been
curated very diligently but still
you may know that there will be some
pathogenic variants in this database
just because there are maybe variants
that have don't
have a high penetrance or variants
that are just related to a specific risk
to
have a disease and if you compare this
with
the variants that are contained in real
world evidence databases
you will see that well those databases
will certainly contain a large number of
frequently occurring data variants that
are should be considered benign
but of course they also contain a larger
fraction of pathogenic variants
and very importantly they contain
ng-specific artifacts
or variants that are frequent because
they occur
in low complexity regions and those
last two types of variants they are
specifically excluded from the gnome ad
database for example so you will never
find them there
but you will find them in your patients
in your real world data
and this means that being able to
compare
to a real world evidence database will
help you
better classify your variants if you're
using such a database make sure that you
also have access to
technical metadata and of course also to
phenotype data it's very important
that if you're comparing to other
patients that you know what these
patients look
like and if these phenotypes have
anything to do with the phenotype
of your own patient and those databases
should also contain
classifications of variants and the
final diagnosis of those patients
please always keep in mind that if
you're
talking about and if you're dealing with
patient data
since genomics is such a new field the
information will change
so it's very important to have
mechanisms in place
that can deal with updates data will be
updated continuously
and of course there will also be
conflicts
so you have to have mechanisms that deal
with conflict resolution
if you don't have that we have a good
example what happens then
in clinvar you have conflicting
assessments of variants
and they make it very difficult to deal
with this information and to really make
use of the data that is contained in
clinvar
so now that i've talked a lot about the
theory of
data sources and how you can utilize
them in the
whole exome diagnostic process
i would like to explain how a good
solution a validated solution
can look like and this is our software
solution varvis
so varvis covers basically and supports
the workflow
starting from the raw data from the
sequencing instruments it covers
the three steps on the right the
bioinformatics the filtering and the
reporting
but most importantly in the very
beginning it gives you immediate
feedback
about the quality of your data and this
is something that
we work with our customers very closely
is monitoring this the laboratory
process and helping them
to optimize and to achieve the level of
quality that's required for
routine diagnostics the software
presents to you
a very clean interface
to collect all this data all the data is
going and stored
into a database so you have the ability
to monitor data over time
and you have the ability you can set
thresholds
for quality parameters and you will be
notified
if any of your samples fails any of
those thresholds here
so you have a very quick overview if
everything is going to plan
and you also know very very quickly
if you have to optimize into a certain
direction
of course a core component of varvis
is the bioinformatics component and
since
varvis is a cloud native
decision support software based and
operated in the cloud
it is very easy to set up and you have
no investment to make into it
infrastructure
that means you also can scale up very
quickly from
small panels to whole genomes or from a
small number of samples to a very large
number of samples
but what is very important from our
point of view is
that the processes are validated and
they are validated both in the sv
analysis and the cnv analysis and we
actually provide this validation
as a service to our customers and this
is how
this looks like in practice you
our customers simply sequence specific
reference samples
as per our instructions and those
samples
go through the regular process as any
other sample
in your laboratory and we
then compare the results in an automated
fashion
with the reference data that means you
obtain
automated validation reports every time
you sequence such a sample
and we also repeat this validation every
time
something changes in the software so you
can always be sure
that the results that you obtain from
the software are valid
the same level of diligence will also
apply to the cnb analysis
we have performed validation projects on
thousands of samples obtained from our
customers
and we always compare to the gold
standard and cnb
analysis which are pcr based methods
and we obtain 100 sensitivity
if the samples comply with our quality
criteria
and at the same time we achieve a very
high specificity
and this is very important if you want
to apply this technology
as a screening tool as first line
diagnostics
if you have a very high false positive
rate here
this will be this would be very cost
inefficient
because you would have to perform a lot
of additional testing
to confirm the many variants that you
find here
so in practice our customers
have all samples being analyzed for cnvs
there's a specific quality control
because the cnv analysis is
more sensitive to quality than the snv
analysis
but in the end most of of the samples
are undergoing this process
and since we achieve such a high
sensitivity
you can be sure if you don't find a cnv
in the data you can be sure that there
is none
and you can very quickly write a
negative report
so then the other step in the process
that we
pay a lot of attention to is the
filtering and the classification
and i explained before what
uh the real world evidence is and what
it is made up
of and we enable you to capture
this evidence and capture the entire
picture of the data of the patient
so it starts from data about how the
data
was generated how the wet lab process
was performed
information from the sequencing
instrument information from
the bioinformatics processing and you
can
amend this information with family
relations with the entire family history
and of course you can add the phenotype
the classification of variance
and the final diagnosis so you bring
everything together
that you have about a patient and this
is stored in a centralized database
and this then enables you to actually
systematically
manage the data that you are generating
so in the beginning we enable you to
capture the data from the single patient
using standardized ontologies but then
you are collecting with every other
patient that you're
diagnosing you're building your own
local database
and this database typically consists of
homogeneous data sets
and you have full access to the analysis
history
and on top of that we aggregate data
from
many different institutions and create a
reference data network
and this allows you to have access
to many data sets in compliance with
international regulations
and i'd like to explain in detail how
this works
and why we are complying with
international regulations
the protection of patient data is
crucial in this setup and is implemented
into the software by design
so if you think of two laboratories
laboratory x and y
or seeing different patients who are
performing diagnosis on different
patients
they transmit only de-identified data to
a centralized database
we're only interested in phenotype
information and genotype information
and if you now think of yourself or your
laboratory
performing whole exome sequencing on a
patient and this is maybe you're the
first data set that you're seeing
you receive annotations to every single
variant
in your data set from the centralized
reference data set
so you receive information how often has
this variant been found in other
patients
has this variant ever been classified in
other patients
and if it has been found in other
patients what are the phenotype
descriptions what are the hbo terms that
are associated to those patients
but it will never be possible to you to
actually access
the entire data set of a different
patient this is entirely protected
now some facts and figures what is
actually not
contained in the database this is data
from
march of this year we have information
in the database
of more than 19 million unique small
variants
the data has been generated from 35 000
patients
those patients are part of 21 000
different families
and 17 000 of those patients have been
described diligently
using standardized ontologies which
makes the data very useful
in the analysis of whole exome data sets
we also collect information of copy
number variations
so at this moment more than 100 000
copy number variations are contained in
the database
and this is data that was generated from
more than 6000 different cases
so this is already a very powerful and
very comprehensive
collection of data sets and now i'd like
to
use a few examples to highlight
the utility and practice of those data
sets
so my first example will just will show
in a very simple
manner how utilizing the alexis database
can accelerate your search for
significant variants
so in this example this is a diseased
child the parents are healthy
and the entire trio was sequenced using
whole exome sequencing
we entered the phenotype into the
software and we are also entering
the family relations between the
individuals into the database so
all three data sets are linked and can
be analyzed accordingly
this is being utilized this information
is being utilized by the software
in the analysis so let's go
through the data review step by step we
are basically starting with
more than 40 000 variants that have been
found
in the patient i'm now applying
very simple filtering against the nomad
database
this is a very severe phenotype and i'm
filtering
only for very rare data variants in the
nomad database so this reduces
the set that i'm looking at to a little
more than 1000 variants
if i additionally apply a filter against
the alexis database
i can even further reduce this number by
a factor of two
so it takes away fifty percent of the
variance that
i would have otherwise have further
downstream have to look at
so this is a very powerful filtering and
it works in the same way as if you
already had
sequenced uh tens of thousands of whole
exomes yourself
and the filtering works um very easily
in the software
you can store any filter configuration
for your data sets in buttons and you
can see here in the screenshot
the yellow buttons are the activated
filters and well just with the press of
two buttons i
can get to the stage of filtering i now
apply
further filtering for impact of those
variants
with respect to any known transcript of
the genes that are they are related to
and i can also apply a
filtering or rather a ranking of my
variants
with respect to how well the phenotype
of the patient
matches with known phenotype
descriptions of the genes
so i end up with about 30 variants in
the end
that i would have to look at in more
detail but
i haven't made use of the family
relations yet so i'm now
filtering for different hypotheses
what the inheritance pattern would be
in my in my trio data set
and i then end up with just three
variants that would fulfill an autosomal
dominant
inheritance patterns and three variants
from
autosomal recessive compound
heterozygous inheritance pattern
so in the end i only have to look at six
variants in detail
and this is a manageable number so it's
always
the goal of the reviewer to reduce the
number of variants to look at
below 10. anything be above that would
be
too much to handle and too much work in
a root routine diagnostic
process
so this is a screenshot of the result in
the software you can see that
the filters that i mentioned were
applied
these are in the screen shot in the back
you can see three three variants that
are
left in the autosomal recessive
component heterozygous filter
and one of those variants is selected
it's
the result is that two of those
heterozygous variants
are identified as causative for the
phenotype a compound heterozygous state
and you can also see that these variants
are now known in the lexus database and
you
wouldn't even miss them because you can
now filter also for pathogenic variants
in those genes my second example
highlights how important it is to
perform
cnv analysis on all of your samples
the cnv data from whole exome sequencing
is so rich
it can basically replace area
diagnostics
and this is an example where two de novo
cnvs were found and this is so
simple that it can be seen at a glance
from those data sets
this is a screenshot from the
exam trio so you can see at the top
the index patient the the child and
the bottom the father and the mother and
there are two
variants visible one variant and both
variants are de novo because
they are not visible in the data sets of
the parents so there's one deletion on
chromosome 21
and nearby there's also a duplication so
this was
again a very clear case and very easily
visible
and highlights very nicely how much
the cnv analysis complements the snv
analysis and the clinical diagnostic
so these this is a slide just
highlighting what you can do
if you have access to an optimized
software platform in using whole exome
diagnostics
there's an example of a laboratory that
started working with us
in 2016. in 2016 they
didn't do any significant number of
whole exomes yet
and as but as you can see by utilizing
uh the power of the barbary solution
they were able to
basically double the number of samples
that they are processing every year
and from the numbers of the just of the
first quarter
they are going to process a few thousand
samples
and this year and i have to point out
that they don't have a bioinformatician
that is involved in the clinical
diagnostics process
and they have published as you can see
you can see here in this link
that a trained scientist can easily
handle 700 cases per year
using this kind of setup
so this concludes my presentation
how diagnostic process
for whole exome sequencing should be set
up
we are free very frequently discussing
topics
around whole exome sequencing in our
blog
feel free to check it out and to provide
us with feedback if there are some
topics that we haven't touched so far
maybe you're also interested in
workshops about clinical diagnostics
using whole exome sequencing
we are hosting these kinds of workshops
and the workshops are conducted by
clinical experts
with a lot of experience with whole
exome sequencing
if you're interested get in touch with
us at events
varvers.com thank you